Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing 12 more incredible
easter eggs you might have missed in Toy Story
4 including one which may break the entire
Pixar Theory!
And we also have an answer from Pixar on whether
this really is Boo from Monsters Inc!
I'll be discussing a few spoilers, so take
care if you haven't seen the new movie yet.
My giveaway is still running, so subscribe,
hit the bell and let me know your thoughts
about Toy Story 4 for a chance to win.
We're kicking off this list with a breakdown
of the opening flashback where there's a number
of intriguing easter eggs and Toy Story call-backs.
As RC's rescue gets underway, look carefully
at the cover of the book that Molly's dolls
give Bo Peep and you'll see a little unicorn
with a rainbow mane and tail.
That's a nod to Rainbow Unicorn, one of the
actresses who worked at Dream Productions
in Inside Out.
"She wants your autograph."
"No, no, Sadness, don't bother Miss Unicorn,
okay?"
"Sorry, she's from out of town."
And when Woody is using Slinky to try and
reach RC, he finds he can't get near enough,
until the Barrel of Monkeys come to the rescue
and give him the extra length he finally needs
to grab hold of the remote control car.
This is a nice call-back to the first movie
where the toys were trying to rescue Buzz
but the monkeys couldn't reach far enough.
"It's too short!
We need more monkeys!"
"Buzz, the monkeys aren't working!
We're formulating another plan!"
This opening scene in Toy Story 4 also fills
us in on how Bo Peep ended up separated from
the other toys.
And the car she's taken away in has an incredible
Pixar easter egg on its licence plate which
reads "RMR F97".
If you're scratching your head about this
cryptic combo of numbers and letters, well,
it's the Unix computer command which somebody
at Pixar ran in 1997 and which accidentally
deleted the whole of Toy Story 2 from Pixar's
servers.
The movie was only saved because one of Pixar's
employees who was on maternity leave at the
time had taken a backup of the movie home
with her about a month earlier.
Toy Story 4's filmmakers said that they "thought
it was appropriate somehow that the licence
plate on the car that takes Bo away almost
killed Toy Story 2."
And as the flashback ends and the Toy Story
4 title comes on screen, the camera pans up
to a blue sky filled with clouds in a nostalgic
call-back to how the first Toy Story opened
with Andy holding up Woody against the blue
sky and white cloud wallpaper in Andy's room.
The orange, white, and black design on the
swim ring we see Bonnie wearing as she plays
with her toys is a delightful easter egg to
the clownfish Nemo from the movies Finding
Nemo and Finding Dory.
When Bonnie goes to kindergarten, look out
for an easter egg on the lunchbox that Woody
hides behind.
On the box, there's a picture of Reptillus
Maximus from the Toy Story TV special Toy
Story That Time Forgot.
"What fearsome dinosaurs are these?"
"Oh?!"
"Greetings, I am Reptillus Maximus."
And it's in Bonnie's classroom where we get
the first possible appearance of Boo in Toy
Story 4.
Ever since the trailer for the movie dropped,
fans have wondered if this is Boo from Monsters
Inc.
Later promotional material gives us a much
better look at this girl and I have to say
she does look an awful lot like Boo.
Boo also seems to make another appearance
later in the film at the carnival game booth
where Buzz ends up with Ducky and Bunny.
One of the girls playing the game has Boo's
characteristic look and many fans have also
said they think it's Boo.
On my other Toy Story 4 easter eggs video,
"The Criticizer" commented that in the carnival
scene Boo tries to win a prize but loses and
when she looks at the carnival worker he doesn't
care.
Now, if Boo really is in Toy Story 4, then
what does that mean for the timeline established
in the Pixar Theory?
Just in case you're unfamiliar, there are
a number of Pixar theories around, but the
best-known one is by Jon Negroni who has suggested
a unified timeline for all the Pixar films.
In Negroni's Pixar theory, Monsters Inc is
supposed to take place well into the future,
several thousand years after the Toy Story
movies, but if Boo is here in Toy Story 4,
how can that be?
Well, the theory says that the monsters in
Monsters Inc are travelling back in time when
they open doors to visit children, so Boo
could be growing up alongside Bonnie and getting
visits from Sully at the same time.
It also makes me wonder if any of these monsters
visited Andy or Bonnie.
However, in an attempt to put people's Boo-related
theories to rest, one of Toy Story's producers,
Jonas Rivera, has weighed in on the matter.
In an interview with Digital Spy the filmmaker
said the following:
"I looked at her again, but it wasn't her.
Maybe I should just say it's Boo, but it's
not Boo.
I don't think we could even use the model
of Boo, it's so old, but we do love Boo.
It's just a kid that looks like her."
Let me know what you think in the comments
below.
Now we need to talk more about the Pixar theory
as there's an easter egg that Toy Story 4's
director Josh Cooley deliberately added to
the movie in reference to it.
Just in case you're unfamiliar, there are
a number of Pixar theories around, but the
best-known one is by Jon Negroni who has suggested
a unified timeline for all the Pixar films.
In an interview with JoBlo, Cooley said that
in the scene where Bonnie and her family are
at the RV park, her mum is sitting outside
reading a book titled "Beyond Infinity: Debunking
Theories of a Shared Universe".
Cooley didn't say whether he was just poking
fun at the Pixar Theory with this easter egg
or was purposely trying to debunk it.
However, it is interesting that in the final
cut of Toy Story 4, the director decided to
change the angle of the shot so that the title
of the book was obscured, though he says he
did that because it was "too distracting for
the audience."
So whether all the easter eggs we love to
talk about in Pixar movies actually add up
to a fully-connected shared universe is still
up for debate and in some ways Toy Story 4
does confirm some aspects of the Pixar theory
even if it raises other questions.
One part of the theory is that toys come to
life thanks to the energy they feed off children's
emotions, and when Toy Story 4 introduces
Forky, he's really confused about why he's
alive.
"Why am I alive?"
"You're Bonnie's toy, you are going to help
create happy memories that will last for the
rest of her life."
On one hand, the fact that Bonnie created
and then loved Forky seems to confirm the
Pixar theory idea that a toy comes to life
from the energy they receive from a child's
emotions.
But there's still that moment in the mid-credits
scene where Forky meets a new cutlery soulmate
who when she asks "How am I alive?"
Forky replies "I don't know".
In fact, Toy Story 4's filmmakers deliberately
added this scene with Forky in order to have
what they've called a "get out of jail free
card".
In an interview with Digital Spy, Josh Cooley
said "Part of me doesn't want to try and answer
all the magic of [why toys are alive].
In Forky's case, Bonnie has given him a new
purpose, but that's not always the case where
toys haven't had kids and are still alive."
There are dozens more easter eggs in Toy Story
4 which you might have missed including A113,
the Pizza Planet Truck, and the Luxo Ball,
all of which are hidden in the antique store
and the carnival.
You should check those out plus over 50 more
easter eggs in my other Toy Story 4 video.
Click the screen to watch it or check the
link in the video description below.
So, how do you think Toy Story 4 fits in with
the Pixar Theory?
Share your thoughts in the comments below
and be sure to subscribe to enter my Toy Story
giveaway!
And do you think that was actually Boo in
the movie?
I've added a poll where you can vote.
Just tap in the top of this video, and after
you've cast your vote, you'll be able to see
the results.
If you enjoyed this, do hit that thumbs-up
button and tap left for my other Toy Story
4 easter eggs video or tap right for some
more Pixar or other videos you're sure to
like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!